have you ever wanted to import python
code directly from the internet
like from a GitHub repo?
well now you can using the magic of cloud Imports
forget the fuss of creating a requirements
txt and installing your dependencies
just import cloud_imports add your GitHub or other
remote repository and whamo bamo it just works
this is the real deal folks
I haven't secretly pre-installed this
prime number library in the background
if I remove the repo from cloud
imports i get an import error
put it back and we're back in business
there are absolutely no downsides to
running code directly from the Internet
it's fast it's efficient it's bleeding edge
and there are no security risks whatsoever
so for the low low price of $39.99 a month ...
okay hopefully by now you've
caught on that this is a joke and
importing code directly from
the internet at runtime is
at best a horribly horribly misguided idea
and at worst a complete
performance and security nightmare
but this code is real
it works it actually downloads
files from GitHub at runtime
dynamically creates modules
and runs the correct code
you can use the inspect
module to see the source code
and to your boss's horror if you ask for the
module's file it gives you the URL
where the file was downloaded from
so the real question for this
video is "excuse me, what??"
and to answer this very articulate question
we need to learn about Python's import system
you're no doubt already familiar
with how imports normally work
but did you know that Python's import
system is accessible from python itself
and it allows you to customize
what the import statement does
this is the purpose of the built-in importlib
to understand importlib there's
just three things you need to know:
finders, loaders, and the system meta path
the overview is that you register
finders in your meta path
and python tries each finder in
turn until either a finder succeeds
or it runs out of finders in which
case you'd get an import error
if a finder succeeds it gives
a specification for the module
that includes the loader that should
be used to actually create the module
then python uses the loader to
create and initialize the module
take a look at the meta path as it is now
the first item in the meta
path is a built-in importer
which is used for finding modules built into
the python interpreter itself
like itertools, sys, and time
then there's this frozen importer which is used in
cases where the interpreter
is embedded into a binary
like if you're using pyinstaller
you can ignore that for this video
and the third path finder one implements the usual
logic looking in directories in the system path
which is how python would find
modules in the current directory
modules installed into your virtual env
and built-in modules that were written in
Python rather than compiled into the interpreter
like the json or inspect modules
all we have to do to get cloud imports
is to add another finder to the meta path
as a fallback for when python
wouldn't find the module any other way
that's all this add repo function does,
add another entry to the meta path
finders just need to implement
one method "find_spec"
which takes the dotted name of the module
and needs to return a module
spec if it can find the module
or None to let the next finder
in the meta path have a try
a module spec just holds the loader and some extra
info like the module name and
whether this module is a package
we implement the cloud finder by replacing
dots in Python imports with slashes in URLs
and appending that onto the base URL
that the finder was constructed with
like the GitHub repo URL
we go out to the internet and download those
URLs and see if we find valid python source
we check both for ".py" files as well as
for "__init__.py" files one directory down
so that cloud imports work with multiple files and
packages as long as they're written in pure python
if we find a valid python file at one of the
URLs then we return a spec for the module
that has a custom cloud loader
holding the downloaded source code
in the loader we need to implement
"create_module" and "exec_module"
which are kind of like "__new__"
and "__init__" but for modules
in create module we create a blank module
and add it to the system module cache
or we get it from the module
cache if it already exists
in exec module we initialize the
module by executing the source
code we downloaded within the module's dictionary
this "get_source" isn't required but it allows the
inspect module to find the
source of the module as well
and that's it
add some convenience functions for adding
different kinds of repos and you're set
zooming out it's surprisingly little code
under 100 lines to completely
change how python imports work
again cloud imports are a mind-bogglingly bad idea
but I think understanding how
to write a cloud importer really
helps you understand how the import system works
and in particular how customizable it actually is
see the import lib docs for more
I'm James Murphy from mCoding
where we do software consulting
check us out at mcoding.io
as thanks for making it to the end if you'd like
a chance to win a license to a JetBrains IDE
make a comment including #mcoding
thank you to my patreon subscribers and
other donors for supporting the channel
slap that like button an odd number of
times and I'll see you in the next one